All right, you're done.
Let's look at the solution.
Okay, we'll begin by adding a log tag
in to our AbstractThreadedSyncAdapter.
Since this stuff runs in the background,
it's helpful to have some logging.
Since we ultimately want the syncAdapter
to run in an unattended mode,
we pull the location query
from our Utility class, and
then we paste in the code from
our existing sunshine service.
We'll have to patch a few things up.
We'll have to call get contexts
to get the current context.
For example, we copy over
the getWeatherDataFromJson function
as well as the addLocation function.
Finally we fix updateWeather
to use our syncAdapter.